As in the previous lessons,
we will be using the iPython Notebook to perform the analysis.
Look in the instructor's notes if you have any further questions as to how to
get started with the notebook for this lesson.
We now set up some of the libraries that we will need to use for this lesson.
We're going to use seaborn and matplotlib for plotting.
We're going to use pandas for handling the data set.
If you scroll down further, you will see a file in the medicare data folder.
That says Medicare_Data_IL_2012.csv.
This is a comma separated variable file.
We created this file especially for
you so that you don't have to use the entire dataset.
If you're interested in using the entire dataset.
Use this commented out codes here to load the entire dataset.
Now use the reads CSV library from pandas to read the data and
load it into a data frame.
As before, to run this piece of code, we just use the play button here.
Once the dataset is finished loading you will receive a message like this.
The f_IL is the pandas dataframe.
We can use the describe function to look at a summary of this data.
Let's run this piece of code.
Once this finishes running you should have a table that looks like this.
The total number of events we have in the data frame is 387,623.
You can slide this bar here to look at the rest of the table.
Now let's look at the top five lines of the data frame.
We can do that by using the head command.